Recebi uma pergunta aqui. Depilação a
laser prejudicial à saúde? Essa é uma
dúvida que aparece direta aqui na
clínica. Então hoje vamos bater um papo
reto sobre esse assunto que tanta gente
tem curiosidade. Será que depilação a
laser faz mal? Eu vou te contar tudo que
precisa saber e sem enrolação. Primeiro,
deixa eu te explicar uma coisa bem
importante. E aqui eu vou usar um
pouquinho de ciência para você entender
o processo. O laser da depilação não tem
nada a ver com radiação ionizante, OK?
Não é raio X, não é radiação nuclear, é
luz, minha gente. Uma luz bem potente,
direcionada, focada, mas ainda assim
luz. Ela age na melanina do pelo, aquele
pigmento que dá cor ao fio, esquenta a
raiz e desativa o folículo piloso. É
como se fosse um choque térmico
localizado. Não mexe com DNA, não altera
a célula, não provoca mutação. Por isso,
pode ficar tranquilo ou tranquila.
Depilação a laser não causa câncer. Até
onde nós sabemos, isso é mito. Agora não
vou mentir para você, o negócio não é
100% livre de perrengue, não. Tem seus
riscos, sim, principalmente quando o
procedimento é feito por gente que não
manja dos paranauês. Imagina só, você
vai numa clínica dessa de fundo de
quintal com aparelho mal calibrado e o
técnico nem sabe direito qual é sua
fototipo de pele. Aí complica, né? O
laser precisa ser ajustado
especificamente pro seu tipo de pele
pelo. É tipo afinar um instrumento
musical. Cada pessoa tem a sua afinação
específica. Os efeitos colaterais mais
comuns são bem tranquilos. Logo depois
da sessão é normal ficar com a pele
vermelha, tipo quando você fica muito
tempo no sol. Pode dar uma coceira, um
inchaço leve, mas isso costuma passar em
algumas horas, no máximo, em alguns dois
dias. Às vezes aparece uma foliculite,
aqueles pontinhos vermelhos que parece
espinha, mas não são. Tudo isso é uma
reação do corpo ao tratamento que é
considerado normal. O importante é
seguir direitinho os cuidados pós laser
que o profissional for te indicar. Mas,
ó, quando o bicho pega mesmo, é quando
rola queimadura, uso inadequado. Isso
acontece principalmente com pele morena
ou bronzeada. E olha que brasileiro
adoram um solzinho, né? O problema é que
quando você tá bronzeada, tem melanina
pele toda, não só no pelo. Aí o laser
fica confuso, não sabe onde mirar
direito e pode acabar queimando a pele.
Por isso que sempre peço pros pacientes,
nada de praia ou piscina pelo menos um
mês antes da sessão. Depois também tem
que maneirar no sol por umas duas
semanas. Tem uma coisa que pouca gente
sabe, as manchas. Pode acontecer tanto
hiperpigmentação
quando a pele fica mais escura em alguns
pontos, quanto hipopigmentação
quando fica mais claro. E é raro, mas
quando acontece pode ser um problemão,
principalmente se for no rosto. Eu já vi
casos de pessoas que ficaram com
marquinhas quadradas ou redondas na pele
no formato da ponteira do aparelho. Dá
uma aflição, né? Por isso que eu insisto
tanto, procure sempre um médico
dermatologista, uma clínica com
profissionais capacitados de verdade,
que t um bom conhecimento, experiência
com o uso do equipamento. E tem as
contradindicações também, viu? Grávida,
por exemplo, não dá para fazer. Não é
que vai prejudicar o bebê, não tem
nenhuma evidência científica disso, mas
é aquela história, para que arriscar uma
coisa que não é urgente, é puro bom
senso. Pessoas com doenças autoimunes
usando certos medicamentos que são
fotosensibilizantes,
com vitiligo, tudo isso precisa de
avaliação especial, não é chegar de
qualquer jeito e sair depilando, tem
todo um protocolo de segurança, ou pelo
menos deveria ter. Agora falando de
tecnologia e aqui o negócio fica
interessante. Temos vários tipos de
laser. Você tem o Alexandrite, o diodo,
o Nag, o Rubi, cada um com suas
características. Por exemplo, o NDAG,
por exemplo, é ótimo pra pele negra,
porque peneta mais fundo e não reage
tanto com a melanina superficial. Já o
Alexandrite é campeão para pele clara
com pelo escluro. Os aparelhos mais
modernos, tipo Light Steer, tem sistema
de resfriamento que protege a pele
enquanto o laser age no pelo. É alta
tecnologia a serviço da sua segurança.
Uma coisa que eu sempre falo pros
pacientes, sim, pode doer, não é aquela
dor insuportável, mas é tipo umas
picadinhas. É como se fossem elásticos
batendo na pele. Tem gente que nem liga,
tem gente que sofre mais. depende muito
da sensibilidade de cada um e da região
do corpo. Virilha e axila costumam ser
mais chatinhas, mas os aparelhos
modernos com resfriamento melhoraram
muito isso. E os cuidados pré e pós são
fundamentais. Antes da sessão, nada de
pinça ou cera, só gilete. O pelo precisa
estar curtinho, tipo um grãozinho de
arroz. Depois da sessão, hidratação é a
palavra de ordem. Protetor solar vira o
seu melhor amigo. Nada de sauna, piscina
com cloro ou mar nos primeiros dias. A
pele tá sensível e precisa de cuidados.
Ah, e tem um detalhe importante sobre
eficácia. Pelo branquinho, grisalho ou
muito clarinho não responde bem ao laser
tradicional. E sabe por quê? Porque ele
não tem a melanina
que é suficiente para absorver a
energia. É como tentar esquentar a água
transparente com luz, não rola. Então,
nesses casos, existem outras
tecnologias, mas a eficácia é bem menor.
Sobre o investimento, porque vamos ser
sinceros, não é baratinho. Uma sessão
pode variar de R$ 900, dependendo da
área e da clínica. Mas pensa comigo,
você gasta quanto por ano com cera,
gilete, creme, depilatório. Faz as
contas, médias são necessárias de quatro
a oito sessões para ter um resultado
bacana com redução de uns 80 a 90% dos
pelos. Depois só uma manutenção anual no
longo prazo compensa pra maioria das
pessoas. E tem os benefícios que ninguém
conta. Acabou foliculite pelo encravado,
irritação de gilete, a pele fica
lisinha, macia, uniforme. Para quem
sofre com esses problemas é uma mudança
de vida. Tem paciente meu que fala que
foi a melhor coisa que fez para a
autoestima. Lembrando que eu não faço os
procedimentos de leis aqui na clínica.
Estou apenas informando a vocês o que eu
sei pelo meu conhecimento. Agora eu vou
te contar uns casos que eu já vi por aí
para você entender a importância de
escolher bem onde fazer. Eu já atendi
gente com queimadura de segundo grau
porque o aparelho estava descalibrado.
Cicatriz permanente porque fizeram em
cima de uma pinta, infecção porque não
seguiram o protocolo de higiene. É cada
história de arrepiar. Por isso que bato
tanto nessa tecla. Procure sempre um
profissional com experiência, com
formação dermatologista
ou cirurgião plástico, alguém que tem
uma formação boa nesse método, pelo
menos uma clínica com supervisão médica
adequada. E uma curiosidade, você sabia
que existem clínicas usando aparelhos de
luz pulsada e vendendo como laser? Pois
é, IPL, que é a luz intensa pulsada
também funciona, mas não é laser
exatamente a diferente. O laser é mais
preciso, mais potente, geralmente tem
resultados melhores, mas tem lugar que
não explica a diferença pro cliente.
Sempre pergunte qual tecnologia eles
estão utilizando. E para finalizar nosso
papo, deixo te dar um conselho de médico
e de amigo. Depilação a leis é segura,
sim, quando bem feita, em bons locais,
com boa formação. É um procedimento
consagrado, aprovado pela Sociedade
Brasileira de Dermatologia. Tem milhões
de pessoas satisfeitas mundo afora. Mas
como tudo, a medicina tem que ser feito
com critério, com cuidado, com
profissional competente. Não é para ter
medo, é para ter responsabilidade.
Lembrando que novamente eu não trabalho
com essa técnica. Só estou aqui
informando a vocês. Então é isso,
pessoal. Depilação a laser não faz mal à
saúde quando feito de forma correta. Os
riscos existem, mas são controláveis com
boa técnica e cuidados adequados. Se
você tá pensando em fazer, pesquise bem
a clínica e o profissional e tire todas
as suas dúvidas com o profissional se
tiver disponível. E lembra, o barato
pode sair muito caro quando você está
tratando da sua pele. Invista em
qualidade, segurança e o seu corpo
agradece. Yeah.